this is tamo hussein standing in for
reviewer richard wakeling
mafia definitive edition may look like a
contemporary video game but it doesn't
exactly play like one
this shouldn't be too surprising
considering it's a remake of the 2002
classic but it also doesn't play like
that game either this is a remake that
has been built entirely from the ground
up with a stunning visual overhaul
expanded story
and greater sense of place yet its
gameplay systems have only been
modernized to a limited extent as a
result mafia definitive edition feels
archaic as it covers the well-trodden
ground of its contemporaries
[Music]
mafia definitive edition's story is far
and away the best part of this remake
you play as tommy angelo a timid cab
driver who gradually turns to a life of
crime in the fictional city of lost
haven during the 1930s
tommy's an interesting and often
conflicted protagonist
and a few new scenes have been added to
the original story to flesh out the rest
of the cast and inject some levity into
tommy's tale
dialogue has also been reworked and
sharpened throughout although the main
story beats of the original game are
still present it's cliched at times well
then maybe you ain't leaving at all
but it's easy to become attached to its
relatively small cast of characters
particularly now that each one has been
enhanced with new voice work and facial
capture from its accomplished cast
aside from looking a whole lot better
these new performances allow for more
subtlety in each scene as facial
expressions are able to express more
than words often can
work
[Music]
there are some missteps such as an
undercooked villain and a predictable
final act
tommy's relationship with his partner
sarah also produces some of the game's
best moments but these scenes are few
and far in between despite being
expanded from the original game and feel
like a missed opportunity to delve
deeper into their relationship
the opening hours are a slow burn too
which only puts a firearm in your hands
once but this gradual build is used to
introduce you to mafia's world of
organized crime and establish an
atmospheric sense of place and time
set during the great depression and
prohibition era of us history mafia
definitive edition features all of the
period-appropriate elements you would
expect large luxurious cars populate the
city streets while zeppelin saw above
the skyline the jazz infused soundtrack
includes songs from artists like duke
ellington and django reinhardt and the
radio broadcast presidential speeches
from herbert hoover and franklin
roosevelt as well as ominous news
reports detailing the rise of hitler and
the nazi party there's also commentary
on the socio-economic factors that were
impacting the united states at the time
lost haven may be a fictional
chicago-esque city but all of these
aspects help to ground it in the
realities of 1930s america
ensuring that you're quickly immersed in
the ambience of its distinctive time
period
whether the american people will pull
themselves
out of this depression i answer
they will if they want to the game world
itself also contributes to this sense of
place while mafia definitive edition may
look like an open world game at first
glance it's actually exceedingly linear
the entire game takes place across 20
levels during which you'll drive when it
tells you to drive
shoot when it tells you to shoot and
sneak when it tells you to sneak the
linearity certainly isn't a bad thing
especially when it comes to world
building
allowing developer hangar 13 to curate
certain scenes
these moments make the world feel
genuine as the city's denizens try to
get on with life amidst the hardships of
the great depression
visually lost haven can look a tad flat
during the day mainly because the
predominant color palette contains
various shades of gray and brown maybe
this is a reflection of the period's
economic collapse but it makes for a dry
city to inhabit fortunately lost haven
comes alive once the sun sets and the
roads are lit by headlights and the
faint dim of street lamps you'll see
most of the city from behind the wheel
of a car there are myriad vehicles to
drive and they're all fun to cruise
around in even if the vast majority
struggle to build up much speed
there's also a palpable sense of weight
to these bulky cars that's keenly felt
when throwing one around a narrow bend
that was your shortcut i lost him didn't
i not
all of them mission design is varied too
even if each one revolves around some
combination of driving combat and
stealth
driving regularly revolves around
traveling from point a to point b but
there are some getaways and chase
sequences to spice things up and even a
lamentable
and mercifully short tailing mission
combat meanwhile takes place almost
exclusively behind pieces of cover while
rudimentary stealth missions are aided
by simple enemy patrol patterns that
guide you through each encounter without
you really having to think about it
[Music]
combat and mafia definitive edition
lacks any sort of exciting dynamism
enemy ai represents an extravagant game
of whack-a-mole as you wait for each
mobster to pop out from behind the cover
before filling their face full of lead
and player movement is so still in that
there's no real incentive to shift
around the battlefield aside from the
rare occasion when an enemy throws a
molotov or grenade in your direction
there is a new melee combat system but
the animations are stiff and each fight
essentially boils down to countering a
single attack and then mashing the
strike button until you can
activate a cinematic final flourish when
it comes to fighting back with firearms
the grunts you're mowing down
aren't bullet sponges per se but they do
take a few shots to dispatch outside of
accurate headshots this wouldn't be a
problem but the dearth of feedback in
their reactions means shooting them
isn't as satisfying as it could
otherwise
have been it's difficult to gauge the
power of a shotgun blast when an enemy
can shrug one off as though it were a
minor annoyance rendering each firefight
stunted from the get-go when you factor
in the lack of enemy types
any type of character or weapon
progression and a limited arsenal the
combat is more dull than it is outright
bad and it simply pales in comparison to
contemporary third person action games
more closely resembling mafia 2 which
was released 10 years ago
there's no denying that mafia definitive
edition is a stunning remake when you
consider everything that was done to
reintroduce the 18 year old game to a
new audience
the changes made to the story both on
the page as it fleshes out more of the
cast
and in the performance booth enhanced
what was already a captivating story
while the revamped visuals breathe new
life into the city of lost haven
unfortunately the rest of the game falls
when you're the one in control
the archaic and repetitive combat hasn't
evolved since mafia 2 was released in
2010 and the years since have dated it
even more
mafia definitive edition might be an
improvement on the original game but its
modernization stops short of the mark
resulting in an uneven game that
squanders its enticing potential
[Music]
you